je vous ai déjà parlé smartphones de
gaming vous ai déjà parlé de la cara
black shark toujours dur à dire black
shark
je vous ai déjà parlé de biens chuck et
blair sharks 2 lors de cette
présentation à paris il ya quelques mois
certains noms que je vous en parle et
j'ai pas trop eu l'occasion et
maintenant le jour est venu tout on va
parler du blackjack 2 qui est super cool
il est dans cette boîte normalement
parce que moi j'ai déjà ouverts et en
plus de ça il ya deux accessoires qui
sont indispensables
c'est ça des petits contrôleur que vous
allez poser et le tout mis bout à bout
vous sort ça alors ça c'est un
smartphone mais c'est aussi une console
portative et c'est tout l'intérêt de ce
produit on en parle
derrière ce que vous en pensez après un
commentaire
[Musique]
si vous êtes un gamer vous savez à quel
point l'expérience d'avoir une manette
ou un clavier une souris pourquoi papa
est hyper importante jouer sur un
smartphone c'est bien mais c'est hyper
limitée et c'est hyper frustrant et
c'est en ça que ce black shark 2 avec
son accessoire est vraiment pu
simplement génial parce qu'il vous
permet justement de profiter d'une vraie
expérience et que je trouve vraiment
hyper bien réussi pour le coup le black
star 2 c'est bien plus qu'un smartphone
vous avez vos petits contrôleur de jeu
que vous venez enlevé comme ça il se
positionne comme ça alors là bas âge
vous avez un smartphone j'ai posé une
coque dessus et si je vous en ai fait
tout vous allez voir vous avez au final
un smartphone comme ça alors aux
smartphones qui fâchent mankono t guinea
c'est normal on lit sur un smartphone du
gaming
le design est sympa moi j'aime bien
votre votre petit est cela qui va venir
ça lui mais alors ce que vous allez
utiliser voyez là c'est très sympa de
petites caméras là le bouton l'a alors
ce bouton à vous le connaissez pas et ce
bouton là il est tout simplement génial
c'est pour entrer dans le mode gaming
qui vraiment bien de temps pour la vie
mais bien évidemment vous retrouver ici
votre prise en usb pour recharger le
micro pour parler
le réglage de volume le micro pour la
réduction de bruit qui cachait derrière
et vous avez un smartphone qui est somme
toute assez classique même si vous voyez
pas toi et que aujourd'hui le fond
d'écran vous avez vous déjà une grande
bande jaune récit avec la caméra vous
avez une grande barre du grand pas que
vous allez voir tout des petits haut
parleurs haut parleurs qui est caché ici
là et un autre haut parleurs qui est
caché ici
ce qui fait que lorsque vous le tenez
comme ça et que vous l'avez en face de
vous bien vous avez du son stéréo en
façade
ça c'est cool mais pour pouvoir
l'utiliser justement en termes de jeu et
bien il faut prendre cette petite coque
vous la prenez vous la mettez vous clip
c est surtout que ça vous permet de
venir utiliser ces deux petits
contrôleur vient installer en fait
offert une vraie manne est donc là vous
le prenez vous l'installez vous venez
glisser de ce côté là c'est vachement
bien fait la même chose avec son petit
frère de l'autre côté vous prenez vous
glisser et là vous avez votre smartphone
vos contrôleurs que vous venez à lui
mais ici sont des contrôleurs vous devez
recharger indépendamment donc chacun
leurs people prises pour recharger ici
vous n'avez un là vous en avez un là
vous avez le bouton ici pour venir
l'allumer et lorsqu'il a lu mais il est
comme ça et c'est vachement sympa rasé
plusieurs boutons vous avez deux boutons
sur le dessus vous
si votre petit joystick voyez ça va ça
reconnaît sa vie à déplacer directement
vous naviguez dans votre smartphone avec
boutons aussi ici pouvait venir
paramétrer pour son disant qu'elle vous
allez être vous avez un petit bouton là
vous avez vos boutons y bx a ici toute
une zone pour venir déplacer la souris
ou ce que vous voulez dans vos jeux vous
regardez ça le déplacement montpetit
pointer ça me fait une petite souris
donc ça c'est cool de boutons également
ici sur le dessus et ça vous fait une
vraie manette de jeu pour des parties de
gaming de ouf
et ça c'est vraiment génial mais ça
serait rien si en fait vous n'aviez pas
ce qu'ils mode lasky boutons que vous
venez pousser et ce petit bouton c'est
la touche sharks qui vous passent dans
le mode gaming et ça pour ça regardez
pas on arrive dans l'expérience ça vivre
on sent qu'elle la performance est bien
alors moi je teste en ce moment de jeu
asphalt 9 est bien évidemment paul j son
cas je m'amuse mon grand classique et je
trouve ça vraiment génial c'est vraiment
génial parce que c'est 100% optimisé
alors le design du smartphone n'est pas
complètement fou quand on regarde comme
ça dit il ya un grand écran mais j'ai
quand même des bordures en aux bordures
en bas c'est vrai c'est pas hyper grave
et ce qui est vraiment bien ce qu'on va
vraiment venir rechercher là dedans
c'est l'expérience de gaming le fait
d'avoir les deux haut-parleurs entre
assad c'est bien parce que ça vous
immerge davantage j'ai quand même dû son
bail à côté un peu déséquilibré y en a
qui est peu plus puissant que l'autre
mais croyez moi lorsque vous jouez s'est
pas vraiment très très grave pas de
priziac le dessus parce que de toute
façon des modes des mines comme ça je ne
vois pas comment vous allez pouvoir
brancher une prise jack pour
éventuellement le bien branché en
bluetooth
si vous le souhaitez ça ça marchera je
trouve un petit peu lourd il ya 205 g
il dispose d'un écran amoled de 6,39
pouces résolution de 1340 par 1080
pixels à 403 pixels par pouce à
fonctionne grâce aux 19 points 5/9 êtes
plusieurs modes cinéma naturel une
protection pour elio fait un mois que je
voulais pas ça s'est vraiment bien ça
marche bien mais truc qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est la partie des nih et
ça pour moi c'est vraiment juste génial
brouille entre le côté vous à votre
petite souris qui se déplace la voyez
que le petit pavé le côté vous voulez
mais lier comme ça c'est vachement
intuitif c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool en plus est si
vous avez vraiment de la performance
nous avons un snapdragon 855 cadencé à
2,84 gigahertz niveau graphique c'est
une adreno 640 vous avez soit 8 soit
douzy'k abraham
elle fait ddr4 x68 de stockage soit 256
go de stockage en fs 2.1 non extensible
l'autonomie
aussi plutôt bonnes avec une grosse
batterie de 4000 millions terreur qui
est compatible quick charge quatre de
qualcomm qui tiendra entre une journée
et demie à deux jours en fonction de vos
usages si vous jouez énormément toute
une journée forcément vous allez arriver
à une journée d'autonomie
ça dépend de vous mais souvent usage
dirait vous allez jouer de temps en
temps d'aller passer des coups de fil
faire plein de choses là il j'en ai mis
deux jours ça fonctionne ya pas de souci
ça c'est vachement bien
en plus de smartphones qui choque pas
particulièrement vous avez un
refroidissement liquide multicouches 3.0
bon dans l'absolu ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que il va pas chauffé énormément
alors forcément vous sentir comme un
petit peu de chaleur lorsque vous allez
faire des parties encore le diable et
mais il se refroidit assez rapidement
c'est plutôt pas mal
avant de parler de la party gaming plus
en détail sa voix vous avez un petit
capteur d'empreintes digitales ici à
capteur optique qui marche bien et qui
est pas non plus du plus rapide
l'ol c'est un androïde 9 paille qui
tourne avec zhang yu wei qui marche bien
qui coule qui est vraiment optimisé pour
la party gaming
pour moi ce qu'elle mieux c'est le mode
sharks lorsque vous voulez pousser
bouton ici vous arrivez dans un autre
monde c'est de mode sharks vous allez
petit contrôleur d'activer ou pas activé
je trouve ça vachement bien voulait
pouvoir alors notre liste de jeux
allaient pouvoir venir rajouter des jeux
lorsque vos contrôleurs sont branchés
vous pouvez retrouver ici
voyez le niveau de batterie de l'un et
de l'autre vous pouvez talonner la
manette pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
passer assez pratiqué ce qui est plutôt
pas mal mais surtout aux tables de
paramétrage de mal être qui joue à fuji
et bien vous allez venir régler
paramétrer directement lorsque vous
jouez c'est à dire que lorsque vous
arrivez dans votre jeu est bien en gros
vous avez juste à voir notre petit
joystick qui marche pour venir déplacer
votre bonhomme
après tout les boutons vous devez venir
les assigner d'anthologie en tout cas à
une zone de l'écran
nadir ben tiens ce bouton l'avenir
correspondre au moment où je saute
mouton la moment où je me couche ce
bouton là où je tire et vous le
paramètre est réellement comme vous
voulez le point positif c'est
qu'effectivement mais votre manette vous
la personnaliser complètement il nous
fait vraiment ce que vous voulez en
fonction de vos besoins et en fonction
de vos habitudes de jeu donc ça c'est
vachement bien
maintenant le point un petit peu négatif
c'est que lorsque vous l'installez pour
la première fois il ya vous devez tout
configurer et ça ça peut être rapidement
rébarbatif dire aller voilà je fais ça
je pars à metge si je ça alors dites
vous bien qu'il prépare t-il d'aller
vous faire défoncer que l'on vous
paramétrez parce que vous mettre à
l'abri c'est souvent trop compliqué mais
bon voilà c'est
un point peu négatif mais en tout cas ce
qui est vraiment cool avec cette manette
c'est que vous êtes une femme vous
l'avez bien prises en un dans un monde
complètement immersif lorsque vous jouez
c'est vachement bien la qualité est là
l'écran est vraiment de bonne qualité le
fait d'avoir l'audio stéréo en pleine
face ça c'est cool et d'avoir la manette
ce confort de jeu comme ça pour moi
c'est vraiment bien et c'est ce qui fait
tout l'adn d'un smartphone de gaming je
vous avait déjà présenté notamment le
roquefort d'asus à quelques mois avec la
mallette complète et tous les
accessoires vous avez l'intérieur et
pour moi on est dans cette idée là et
c'est vraiment ça qui fait tout
l'intérêt de ce smartphone de gaming cet
accessoire là ils doivent tous être
beaucoup plus loin l'expérience et qui
va faire que ce smartphone bien qu'il
ait de la performance bien qu'il ait de
la puissance vous seriez vachement
limité si vous n'aviez pas cette petite
manette là et c'est là où réellement
réside tout l'intérêt de ce smartphone
de gaming donc voyez l'expérience de jeu
comme ça c'est vachement agréable
vous avez votre pad hop vous venez
naviguer comme ça hop
moi j'ai paramètres et le bouton pour
shooter pour sauter et à quatre pattes
et comme ça je peux vraiment aller où je
veux faire ce que je veux donc sans tain
expérience d'utilisation à la partie
habitée je trouve ça vraiment trafic
donc là tout de suite je sais pas hyper
balèze rien j'ai aucune arme je suis
tout est dans la nature et donc voyez là
c'est pareil sur la streif neuf jeux
d'ea
je lance le turbo cheveux les 2 en même
temps et je peux tout gérer directement
ici avec mon pâle et ça c'est vachement
cool je peux changer aussi ma direction
même temps et là c'est qu'un petit
exemple mais c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment top
et vous seriez sur asphalte aux plages
de l'autre côté sur la boucle que vous
soyez sur un cheval sur n'importe quel
autre jeu je trouve ça vraiment juste
topissime dont vous vivez l'expérience
est vraiment génial et moi c'est ce que
j'adore ce sens vraiment cool lorsque
vous voulez vous divertir voulait
profiter de jeux vous voulez avoir côté
immersif vous prenez vous pleurez vous
posez vous partez vous jouez c'est plein
air de premier groupe mais c'est vrai
que c'est vachement bien et je trouve ça
cool alors à côté de ça vous avez aussi
des caméras et c'est un smartphone qui
fait aussi des photos et se glatch and
the il a aussi je ferai mon dieu le dira
il a vraiment double module photo
l'arrière 48 médiatique cet ouvrage
remporte 75 une 13 mégapixels tu ouvre à
f 2.2 et l'abandon des signes toute
petite caméra puis elle fut fera le job
pour quelques petits souvenirs et croyez
le ou non je trouve que dans l'absolu le
rendu est plutôt bien
des photos qui sont pas trop mal
colorisées assez précises facile pour
prendre vos clichés se trouve qu'il ya
un très bon rendu c'est assez net c'est
à ses qualités je trouve ça c'est bien
probable pourrait sur un smartphone de
guémy l'expérience et foule et sachent
qu'on soit vraiment mais regardez là par
exemple rendu le détail sur la jolie
petite fleur s'avoue fins ou derrière le
focus se fait très rapidement et donc je
trouve qu'il ya il ya un vrai beau
boulot qui est fait en tout cas un
traitement logiciel là dessus sur ce
black shark d'eux mêmes sur la caméra de
celles figurant du pas trop mal alors
salissent légèrement mais ça va c'est
pas trop exagérer plus de ça on est sur
un smartphone qui a du bluetooth 5.0 qui
compatible à péter x et y ptx hd et qui
vachement bien alors maintenant
collective de la douloureuse
c'est ce qu'on appelle la douloureuse
six mois c'est l'addition c'est ce que
vous allez le payer la cuenta si vous
êtes espagnole alors c'est un smartphone
qui proposait en de config 8 gigas de
ram 128 go de stockage
12 il ya de ram 256 go de stockage une
giga de ram 128 go de stockage 549 euros
c'est franchement hyper bien positionné
en tarif 12 giga de ram 256 go de
stockage à 649 euros alors le smartphone
et la coque
si par contre vous l'avoir les petits
contrôleurs en plus ce qui pour moi est
complètement indispensable d'acheter le
smartphone son sein pour moi ça ne serve
dumas n'ont pas grand chose ou être
performant mais vous allez perdre
vraiment un expérience ça ça coûte 79
euros donc on recourra sur la plus
grosse config ans pour 750 euros vous
avez ça complet et ça pour moi c'est
vachement bien je trouve ça vraiment
cool l'expérience est là vous avez de la
performance une machine qui est bien et
je vous dis je vous fais une console
portative ça vous fait nintendo switch
ou une console que vous pouvez emmener
partout avec vous et pourrait même
téléphoné avec et faire des photos donc
ça c'est plutôt cool a vous de me dire
que vous en pensez un banc commentaires
qu est ce que vous pensez du blague
chaque 2 est-ce qu'il vous intéresse oui
non quoi comment est ce que vous le
promets bien vous marquez tout ça quand
à moi je donne rendez vous dès demain
voire peut-être après demain c'est l'été
c'est les vacances
je suis un peu plus cool et surtout je
vous emmène dès la semaine prochaine en
corée on part en corée on décolle on y
va ensemble ça c'est cool
vous pourrez fille mon périple plus
régulier sur instagram ça c'est cool
vous emballe pédebidou à demain à
bientôt enfin très bientôt plus on va
vers des bibelots cacao
[Musique]